today we once again travel back to Japan
but this time to discuss the Izanagi and
there is an ami the primordial gods of
Japanese mythology and Shinto religion
they were the brother and sister deities
that many believed to have created the
islands of Japan along with many of the
Shinto gods and Carmy
their names were thought to mean he who
invites and she who invites and it's
believed that they were the eighth and
last pair of brother and sister deities
to be born before the world was formed
when the heavens and the earth were
separated out of chaos the brothers and
sisters appeared standing on a floating
bridge or platform where the eldest
generation of karma assigned Izanagi and
Izanami to bring order and structure to
the world but in order to help them do
so they were given a jeweled spear named
Amano Nobuko standing atop of the
heavenly bridge they stirred the oceans
with the tip of their spear and each
time they lifted their spear the
droplets that felt would form an island
the first of these islands was the honor
God or Shima and this would be the
island they made their home when they
had established themselves on the island
of onigoro
they decided it was time to start a
family and here's what a story gets a
tad weird the marriage ceremony itself
involves circling around a sacred pillar
with both gods moving in opposite
directions and saying what would equate
to a modern day I do but it was the
Izanami who spoke first during the
ceremony which was considered incorrect
at a time when women taken initiative in
Japan was frowned upon as a consequence
that is an Okie not speaking first
during a wedding ceremony when his wife
eventually gave birth to their first
child that child was horribly misshapen
with no bones in his body which led to
him being referred to as the leech child
unfortunately that child was placed on a
boat and abandoned to float away this
child was known as Hiroko and he would
become a patron of fishermen and one of
the seven day ''tis associated with good
fortune the second attempt at having a
child of rasa's unsuccessful as their
first and when they eventually consulted
with the elder carny they decided that
their marriage ceremony would have to be
performed once again the second attempt
that the marriage ceremony was performed
correctly and is an army gave birth the
hundreds of Carmi and many of the
principal islands located in Japan
giving birth to so many deities
eventually took its toll on Izanami she
gave birth to the comi of the seas the
mountains the wind and the trees the
earth Azov began to take shape but when
she eventually gave birth to Kaka to see
the Carmi of fire she was badly burned
many more deities would be born from her
tears as she cried out in pain but the
injuries she sustained or too severe and
she would eventually die follow another
fee's wife Izanagi took it upon himself
to avenge his own army he took his sword
and he cut cogito chin to pieces from
each piece of the fire deity that fell
to the ground dozens of new Carmy were
born without his wife Izanagi was lost
and he attempted to journey to the
underworld to retrieve her but when he
arrived he saw that she had already
eaten the food of the underworld making
it so that she was forbidden to ever
return to the land of the living this is
somewhat similar to what we see in Greek
mythology with Hades given Persephone
the pomegranate to ensure that she had
to return to the underworld izanagi was
told that his wife would be allowed to
return as long as he promised to be
patient and not lay his eyes upon her
again until she was ready this process
was extremely long in his a Nagas
patience grew thin until he could wait
no longer he attempted to visit his wife
once again but this time he was shocked
when he laid his eyes upon her as all he
saw was his wife's decomposing body
naturally she was displeased that her
husband had broken his promise seeing
her in this unflattering state he would
eventually be chased out of the
underworld by the eight thunders and in
order to stop his pursuers he threw down
his stick in their path creating the two
gods associated with the road schemata
no kami and Yasha Matta hiki often
referred to as dosage in a name given to
deities who were thought to protect
travelers this part of the story does
resemble another Greek myth the story of
Orpheus the musician who was told that
he could return his wife from the
underworld as long as he did not look
back at her until they reach the land of
the living
much like izanagi he was unable to do so
gazing upon his wife and breaking the
promise he had made when izanagi had
finally reached the land of the living
he decided that he would block the
entrance of the underworld with an
enormous stone in order to cleanse
himself from a darkness and impurities
that he had encountered whilst in the
underworld he performed a ritual in a
nearby river
it was during this ritual that many of
the Shinto gods were born from the
impurities being washed from izanagi's
body
izanagi in Izanami were amongst the
oldest deities in Japanese mythology and
Shinto religion and they were often held
accountable for the creation of the
world and many of the deities had
existed if you do have any stories or
different variations relating to the
Izanagi and there is an ami then feel
free to share them with me in the
comments below but as always I've been
your host mythology and fiction
explained
you